du bonjour tension mais c'est toute une
bataille que vous avez mené
vous savez dans quoi vous embarquer dans
quelques années
salek long ardu on s'en doutait mais
évidemment c'est pas ça qu'il n'est
qu'ils auraient à l'a été mais le vivent
c'est une expérience mais je regrette
pas de l'avoir entrepris comment vous le
qualifiez pour vous c'est une grande
victoire sur toute la vie c'est une
grande victoire parce que comme disait
on n'a pas notre mot à dire sur notre
naissance puis c'est normal qu'on veut
en avoir un petit liberté pour notre
mort et c'est moi j'ai eu récemment 74
ans elle comme ceux touchant beaucoup
plus jeunes le paye différents mais les
intérêts coincé de rente à un moment
donné moi j'ai jugé puis de preuves à
faire pour les autres j'ai pu de me
prouver à moi-même et j'ai eu une vie
extrêmement remplie avec des habits
extraordinaire alors j'ai j'ai pas je ne
suis pas amer parce que j'ai saisi
toutes les opportunités qui se
présentaient est ce que ce qui est
surprenant c'est peut-être non pas que
je me retrouve dans l'état où je suis
maintenant mais que j'ai réussi à mener
la vie que j'aime et contre tous les
pronostics notamment médicaux mais vous
vouliez vous étiez arrivé à la
conclusion que vous vouliez qu'on vous
laisse partir
oui comme les gens doutent jamais
demande pourquoi vous voulez mourir je
veux pas mourir je vais cesser de
souffrir et sable est il que pour ça il
faut passer de vie à trépas septembre au
large et votre souffrance pour vous ça
doit être ça le critère pour dire oui ou
non à quelqu'un de lui donner le droit à
mourir dans la dignité ou c'est sur le
seul critère c'est la souffrance c'est
très difficile c'est de la souffrance
physique et morale parce que sentir sont
tout en haut dans tous les deux cadres
de ce torchon et moi même on est atteint
de maladie dégénérative
alors ça moi je compare souvent à un
homme a rappelé à mes deux parents
adoptifs qui sont mahmoud valeur à un
escalier condé saints n'ont pas marche
par marche
mais quand déboule par palier on sait
qu'on s'envoie verbe pignes on sait pas
exactement quand et comment ça va se
produire mais disons que on est averti
c'est pour ça que je dis que mon défi
est le pire jour de ma vie c était celui
des dernières années de vivre sans
espoir mais on évitait le désespoir
c'est pas évident et le grand paradoxe
de ce qui arrive actuellement c'est que
le fait qu'on vous ait refusé de mourir
vous avez pris cet espace qui restait de
votre vie pour mener un combat que vous
avez gagne donc j'ai comprenez vous
c'est tout à fait ça vous est ce que ça
vous fait réfléchir en temps mais dans
le fond ma présence
même avec mes souffrances rétine
oui j'aime bien que me poser cette
question la question comment n'est pas
ça dépend de la personnalité de les gens
ça touche tout le monde les jus les
politiciens moi je suis allé et machines
go getter ehealth ouvert un vrai lion
n'est pas passée la vie mon nez on est
rarement plein
mais là vous dites j'ai fait une tâche
énorme avec ce combat devant la justice
le vous dit laissez-moi m'en aller je
retrouve ma liberté et légendes m'a dit
c'est tout à fait logique pour pas aussi
directement mais qu'est ce que vous
allez faire ou sous-entendus
qu'interscope
j'ai répondu très simplement pour moi je
vais digérer je veux parler des amis
mais pour moi c'est une question de mois
alors ça c'est bastille c'est bien comme
ça j'ai pas précipiter un c'est clair
l'objectif est clair d'ici quelques mois
d'ici quelques mois
qu'est ce que vous demandez à la classe
politique
face à ce jugement un document d'abord
qu'ils n'aillent pas en appel jeu où
vous étiez bien court tirs seulement
prévisible de sa peau d'affaires là
encore une fois faut se concentrer sur
la souffrance des gens qu'est ce que
vous demandez aux chefs sont en campagne
et ayant candidat si vous êtes élu est
ce que vous vous engagez à modifier le
code criminel c'est surtout au fédéral
que ça nous gêne aux entournures suivant
les conclusions de la juge baudoin et je
pense que c'est une question c'est pas
ça va être deux balles de coiffure mais
le fait que le jugement soit sorti hier
la couverture extraordinaire qu'on a eu
le jeu me voir encore demain on constate
souvent que les hommes les femmes
politiques agissent souvent en réaction
à l'opinion populaire et ça ça revient
au rôle des médias est à ce moment
l'option on n'en parle plus
les gens sont plantés d'acquiescer
l'objet devenue une experte dans l'est
médicale à mourir
vous avez tout écouter l'été les gens
qui sont qui craignent les dérapages qui
craint que ça aille trop loin qu'on
commence dans les sièges celle des à
dire des malades le vous serez peut-être
bien aussi est est ce que ça vous fait
peur
par ailleurs non mais j'apprends que
satisfaire à certaines personnes et
coûté 4 en fait quand on prend de plein
changement agissant des tonnes qui
touche beaucoup de gens il ya des
questions cartésien il ya des questions
très émotive ou c est moi j'avais garde
sa pige me dit écoutez ça me rappelle
les débats autour de l'avortement
quelques années où on a ajouté le même
épouvantail que les statistiques
prouvent qu ici aussi dans d'autres pays
qui ont sous une forme ou sous une autre
des législations comparables y a pas eu
de dérapage
puis on on parle toujours des influences
indues pour pousser les gens à l'aide
médicale à mourir on parle jamais des
autres pressions de ceux qui disent vos
sports de pau mais les deux sont ces
désagréables ses portes pour les gens en
terminant même l'éducation qui n'ont
plus leur tête mais qui voudrait signer
un consentement pour avoir l'aide
médicale à mourir une fois atteints
d'alzheimer
une fois par exemple qu'ils ne
reconnaissent plus leur entourage
est ce que vous êtes d'accord qu'on nous
à ces gens là aussi cette pause est
moins si c'est pas le débat actuel medal
débat global moi je serais d'accord
allez les phases surtout compte tenu du
fait que notre population vieillit et
moi pour avoir vu mes deux parents
adoptifs mauvais dans ce même le
sentiment d'impuissance on voudrait être
à leur place je pense que ce jugement-là
va ouvrir des portes et veut redonner de
l'espoir à beaucoup de gens qui n'en ont
plus
mais éventuellement je souhaiterais et
je pense qu'on va y venir un
consentement préalable parce que on peut
par la bouche était trop grosse
je pense que là on s'en va vers son
autre ça ouvre votre cause a ouvert tout
un débat oui hélas bild-boy toujours bon
exactement je vous souhaite quoi dans
les prochaines semaines prochains mois
bon accueil dans les milieux politiques
pour que je vois que c'est qu'on a fait
un travail utile
ensuite monsieur tout chaud et moi même
et que ce soit nos soins soit vécu avec
mes grands amis comme ils m'ont
accompagné tout au fil de ma vie entre
vous êtes une femme de liberté oui et
traiter dessus et comme je suis un vrai
lion alors je dis souvent on n'est pas
facile à vis mon est rarement l'herbe
anglaise merci beaucoup
on va suivre ce débat là c'est moi mais
c'est merci